Sooooo like....how do you fairly and justly
execute someone?
...I'm asking for a friend.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
Did yall hear about what happened in Oklahoma?
Ah man....really disturbing.
I'll spare you the details, but basically
there was an execution and the state botched
it; so botched that some are calling what
happened unconstitutional, a form of cruel
and unusual punishment.
In the wake of the chilling incident, one
of the most comprehensive reviews of the death
penalty in the USA has been released by a
bipartisan research group and panel of criminal
justice experts called The Constitution Project.
The report doesn't take a STANCE on the death
penalty, what it does is look over the 32
states where the death penalty is legal and
offers some *humble suggestions* for those
states.
The experts agree that what happened in Oklahoma
should never have gone down -- it was the
result of an untested drug cocktail that wasn't
administered by trained medical staff.
As it turns out, qualified professionals who
are willing to administer the death penalty
are kinda hard to come by.
Historically, during an execution, states
are pretty secretive about all these details.
The report states that there needs to be more
transparency about where the drugs come from,
who's administering what, and that these drug
cocktails?
They've gotta go.
Instead, they advise that states adopt a single
drug method.
This is actually already in place in 8 states.
Another centerpiece of the 216 page report
is a discussion about executing the innocent.
You know, just casual dinner chatter.
They advise that only evidence obtained by
INDEPENDENT, ACCREDITED forensic labs be allowed
in capital punishment cases.
Currently, there are no strict federal standards
and some labs have been accused of working
with law enforcement -- leaving room for bias.
The Innocence Project, a DNA testing organization,
found that of 225 wrongful convictions, half
of them involved improper tests done at labs
without accreditation.
Folks, that's....a lot of bad science...which
is kind of a problem when we're talking about
killing someone....
Along the same lines, the report addressed
serious concerns about executing the mentally
ill.
Because that's a thing that happens, even
though it's illegal.
This is because in some states, what the government
defines as "intellectually disabled" is different
than how clinicians and scientists define
it.
So the report also suggests scientific standards
and procedures for testing intellectual disabilities.
One of the members of the project, Mark Earley,
who himself was the Republican attorney general
of Virginia while 36 executions took place,
said quote "We hope these recommendations
will be embraced by officials from both parties
in Washington and around the country.
There's nothing conservative about executing
an innocent person, and leaders who support
the death penalty bear the greatest responsibility
in ensuring it is administered more fairly."
Welp, that's a whole lot to chew on -- and
that's only a few of the 39 policy recommendations!
Let me know what you folks think about the
report down below and I'll catch you next
time with more DNews updates!